I'm Stephanie yatesanyabuile a licensed
marriage and family therapist I'm here
to answer your questions from Twitter
this is relationship support
[Music]
underscore Jesse Beauty how do I tell my
closest friend her boyfriend begged me
for sex
so I think the best thing you can do in
a situation like that is find
opportunity when your friend is already
disarmed you never want to pull
something like this out when you all are
already in the course of an argument for
example I would go ahead and let her
know that this is something that's going
on will she get mad at you there is a
possibility that she will but what she's
upset about is the information itself
and she's probably very embarrassed
humiliated but if you keep this
information to yourself what does that
say about your friendship with her
that's going to call into question the
relationship itself between you and her
and so you try your best to be as humble
as possible and let her know the reasons
why you've chosen to share this with her
and let the chips fall where they may
hopefully she can be mature and
understand that you have her best
interest at heart but if she's at a
place where she's not ready to accept
the truth and she wants to be upset with
you then you kind of have an eye-opening
experience about the person that you're
considering to be your friend from
Lindsay W is it ever okay to ghost
someone I would say if you feel like
you're unsafe if you're dealing with
someone who might be stalking you or has
anger issues and you feel like you can't
trust this person can handle the
information that you're not interested
anymore that is the only time that I
would say that it's okay to ghost but we
see most often is that people have a
hard time trying to have difficult
conversations with people with this
opportunity a person that you clearly
don't care that much about to where
you'd be fine to never talk to them
again this is actually a great time to
practice having difficult conversations
sharing your feelings and dealing with
the person who you may be making upset
so that way when you are with the person
that you love and care about and you
need to have a difficult conversation
you're a little bit more prepared to do
that because you've got some practice in
Michael the boy how do I tell my partner
some of his friends are losers
[Applause]
um
so if you feel like your partner is
surrounding themselves with people that
you don't think are investing and your
partner's success definitely find a way
to have that conversation with them but
what you don't want to do is establish
yourself as the enemy you never know the
conversations that your partner is
having with their friends behind closed
doors there could be times where those
people are standing up for you in a way
that you didn't know was actually
sustaining your relationship so be very
careful when you establish yourself as
the enemy between your partner and their
closest friends because you might not
win that battle and if at the end they
choose their friends over you you're the
one who started the war from Key blade
Kate can I ask you guys a question if
you guys are in a relationship and your
partner is flirting with other people
would you consider that cheating or
disloyal within one relationship you
might be in a position where flirting is
actually expected I know some couples
that that fine flirting to actually be
ego boosting and they like to see that
their partner can still pull someone if
they want it to but in other
relationships it can be a major hit on
your partner's self-esteem to see that
you're interested in someone else
attracted to someone else and then going
to the next step and actually acting on
those feelings you definitely don't want
to have one person who is okay with it
and another person who is not so make
sure you're having those conversations
very early on in the dating process
about what defines cheating and
disloyalty within your relationship so
that you're not moving forward with
someone who has very different ideals
than you do from baliholic serious
question how do I know if I'm a
narcissist if you are even looking at
yourself in such an introspective way
most of the time you're you're not a
narcissist because the thing about
narcissistic personality disorder is
that one of the requirements is a very
limited self view you don't see the pain
you cause the people around you as a
matter of fact you're looking at
everyone else like why are they causing
me all of this distress from Jay Gaddis
opposites do attract and that even
applies to your attachment Styles but
does having different attachment Styles
mean you're with the wrong person one of
the main things that we're talking about
when we're talking about attachment
Styles which for anyone who's unfamiliar
with attachment Styles means that a lot
of us have a bit of a predisposition for
how much intimacy we're comfortable with
in relationship if you're anxiously
attached for example you're probably
going to want a lot of validation from
your partner you'll want somebody who is
telling you they want to be with you
who's comfortable holding hands who can
help you know that they are committed to
this relationship maybe more often than
another person would if you have a
secure attachment that means that you
don't need a ton of validation from your
partner and you also don't need a ton of
space from your partner but if you have
an avoidant attachment style you tend to
value your Independence and autonomy and
you need a lot of space it's not that
you're not interested in having intimacy
within your relationship but you might
not be the type of person that's
interested in spending 24 7 with your
partner as a person who's anxiously
attached might be more interested in
doing so you can be with someone with a
different attachment style but you do
want to pay close attention to what that
different attachment style is from the
real J Dior timeline's too peaceful who
do you all think should pay on the first
date okay I'm gonna get canceled here
this is the thing that I'm gonna say
that people are not going to agree with
me about but I truly believe that if you
are interested in pursuing a long-term
relationship with someone you should
look at that as a partnership from the
outset so I'm big ongoing Dutch you know
so that way if this is a person that
you're interested in spending more time
with both of you have more funds to make
that a reality now I do understand that
for some people it's important to know a
person's intentions from the beginning
and paying for a meal or an activity is
a way that that person can prove to you
that they are really interested in you
is that really telling you if that
person is interested in you because they
could be paying for your meal and five
other people's meals and it doesn't even
matter from pulse Nigeria 247 how do you
know that someone is gaslighting you
especially those you are in a
relationship with gaslighting is another
one that we're hearing a lot more about
these days when I think of gaslighting I
think of someone who might be
intentionally or even sometimes
unintentionally making you second guess
yourself making you second guess your
feelings you know maybe you saw
something happen and they say something
like that didn't happen so sometimes it
could be outright lies and sometimes
it's something like oh you really don't
feel like that right they might be
telling you you're just acting you
really don't feel that way stop trying
to make a scene they don't validate or
value your perspective on how you're
feeling or what you're seeing and most
of the time they're trying to convince
you to see or feel things a different
different way from Moon areas should I
leave my girlfriend who doesn't trust me
and is very insecure or work it out well
we're talking about a relationship where
you have one partner who is very
insecure that is actually language that
we still use when we talk about
attachment Styles secure versus insecure
attachment sometimes when you have a
partner who is acting very insecure they
probably have an anxious attachment
Style and what that means is that
they're going to require a lot of
validation from you now for you if
you're the person that's got to provide
that and that is your limit you're like
I cannot constantly make this person
feel at ease in our relationship it's
not my job to try to heal them from
previous relationship wounds I fully
respect that in that case absolutely end
things from Lindy R can a relationship
recover from cheating a relationship
absolutely can recover from cheating if
both people are committed to making that
relationship work so if you're dealing
with the relationship after there's been
a betrayal and trust it's not going to
just go back to what it looked like
before you had that betrayal and Trust
if you were with the person who no
longer believes you when you say that
you're at a certain location for example
and they would feel more comfortable if
you would share locations you have to be
open to hearing their request if you're
looking to have that relationship
continue forward and if you're the
person who got cheated on you have to
humble yourself and be open to having a
conversation about the gaps and the
relationship that could have led to that
cheating so after cheating it's
extremely important that you both focus
in on what's going to be required to
rebuild the trust and it could take
years for that to happen from Adrian
loves Gigi do open relationships really
work asking for a friend and this is
another one where it's going to be
highly dependent on the people who are
within the relationship you have to know
what people are needing so if we go back
to attachment styles for example simple
if you've got two people who have an
avoidant attachment style they both need
a lot of space and dependence autonomy
an open relationship might be perfect
for them because they don't have to feel
trapped or imprisoned in a relationship
that's very limiting and they do still
have the stability and consistency of
having that one partner that they will
achieve their long-term goals with from
a Rouge Waheed 3 what causes a marriage
of 10 15 years to fail what changes or
does not change I always thought the
respect and understanding gets better
with time but the cases around me are
showing otherwise what we often see is
that as relationships progress through
really critical Milestones it requires a
reconfiguring of the identity of each of
them individually as well as how they
fit as a couple so the empty nest
syndrome for example you've got a couple
who maybe got married had kids within
the first five years then they spend the
next 20 25 years trying to launch those
kids what happens when the children are
completely out of the house and now it's
just the two of you and you don't
remember how you relate to one another
anymore you don't know your hobbies your
interests you don't know how much space
you need and you start really noticing
that this retired life that you envision
for yourselves is just not compatible
from underscore oty underscore how do
you know if he's the one you want your
relationship ideally to represent a safe
haven for you so if you're having stress
at work with your family you want this
person and this relationship to be the
place where you can relax at the end of
a stressful day so even though in the
beginning these relationships aren't
always that appealing because they can
seem actually kind of boring those are
the types of things that you want to pay
attention to where there can be nice
longevity in the relationship because
you guys are creating a dynamic where
you can weather a lot of different storm
together from Inspire chat how does
developing self-love help to strengthen
your relationship when we are expecting
the people in our lives to make us feel
worthy we are setting ourselves up for
failure because they're humans and
they're going to fail so when you have
those self-love practices of setting
side time and having boundaries and
taking care of your body all of these
things that tell yourself hey if no one
else comes through for me I'm going to
come through for myself it makes it a
lot easier for the people around you to
show you that they love you and it feels
like an add-on instead of a need for 13
honey do love languages matter to you
this is a great question I think love
languages are really important when it
comes to Love Languages I find that it's
a really great way for you to identify
your needs compared to your partner's
needs there are five love languages you
have words of affirmation physical touch
quality time acts of service and Gifts
most of us are going to score on all of
those to some capacity but you want to
see what are your big hitters for me for
example it's words of affirmation but a
really interesting thing that we don't
talk enough about when it comes to Love
Languages is that it actually also gives
you insight into some of the most severe
ways that you can hurt your partner so
if we were to continue with the words of
affirmation for a person who really
values words if you say demeaning things
especially in front of a group of people
those things are going to affect a
person with the words of affirmation
love language more than a person with
physical touch for example next from
stage five social can you have a
compromise without a sacrifice like what
if my partner wants kids and I don't how
do you navigate that without sacrifice
this is a great question and it's one of
those things that needs to be discussed
in the beginning of your relationship if
you want to have children and your
partner does not want to have children
or vice Versa that's the type of thing
that you really cannot compromise on at
the end of the day someone is not
getting what they want and they're going
to have to compromise their values and
when it comes to kids I personally think
that's the kind of thing that you should
not be compromising on that's it that's
all the questions we had I hope you
learned something till next time